Speaker 1: You guys remember massive dumps? Not
and I'm not talking about those of you who have
little babies at home. I'm talking about this
phrase that Donald Trump started using to signal
fraud in 2020, that there were dumps of ballots
seemingly without even a hint of understanding
the absurd and ironic nature of that phrase. Just
moments before the Arizona gubernatorial race was
called against Kerry Lake. Lake appeared
on Fox News with Jesse WATTERS and again,
without, like, a shred of self-awareness of how
stupid they sound talking about these dumps,
they started talking about dumps. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: What's going to happen when we
hear about this vote dump in about, I don't know,
minutes? It could be Kerry.
Speaker 3: I don't know. We know.
We think we should be in good shape.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we think it's going
to be a pretty favorable dump.
Speaker 3: The 100. I'm going to
look at my notes, 150,000 ballots that have not
been counted yet. And 94,000 of those are in
Maricopa County, where they took our sacred vote.
And they and they just made a mockery of it.
Speaker 1: It's. They dumped all over the boat.
Speaker 3: Outrageous. Jesse, what happened? I
had a man come up to me at breakfast yesterday.
Speaker 1: And he had tears in his eyes. No,
sir, said.
Speaker 3: I showed
up to vote. There was a three hour line. They
said the tabulator machines were not working.
I drove across the way and went to another 15
minute drive to another center and the printing
printers weren't working there. No toner in them.
I drove another 20 minutes and finally voted.
It was a half a day odyssey to cast my vote and
we're getting thousands of people reaching out,
saying the exact same thing. We don't know how
many people just finally gave up because it was so
hard to vote. And when they did get to the front
of the line only to find out the tabulator wasn't
going to count their vote, it was all right.
Speaker 1: So anyway, she's going on about
things going beyond just dumps at this point
in time. Remember that every one of the claims
that she made was either refuted or explained.
There was an issue with the tabulator. The only
person that was going around saying Leave
this polling place and go to a different
one to have your vote counted. Were Republicans in
support of Carrie Lake? That was a self-inflicted
blunder. The election officials from Maricopa
County, who, by the way, are Republicans,
came out and said, listen, there was an issue
with with the tabulator, we fixed the issue,
everything's fine. And of course, they are relying
on old tropes, in this case, the infamous massive
dumps. Quote, Just because you hear dumps doesn't
mean anything was stolen. But remember this iconic
moment from failed former President Donald Trump?
Speaker 2: And what happened if you watched the
election? I was called by the biggest people
saying, congratulations, political people,
congratulations, sir. You just won the
election. It was 10:00. And you looked
at the numbers and I'm sure you felt that
way, right? This election was over. And then
they did dumps they call them dumps, big,
massive dumps in Michigan and Pennsylvania.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And the Maria BARTIROMO
moment where she adjusts her glasses as
Trump repeats that there were dumps is really
just a it's I believe it's one of the most
important moments in political media history
of the United States. All right. So they went
the route of the dumps and the dumps were
not in their favor. And Carrie Lake lost.